uh we're going to move on to our our
next speaker uh who's a uh federal
government defense project manager and
also a published author but in addition
to those two fantastic titles she's also
someone who has uh kidnapped uh deployed
surveillance team to do her bidding uh
ladies and Gentlemen please put your
hands together to Sarah Adams hi
everyone thanks for having me here today
um I'm the one talking about I guess the
one controversial topic of this whole
event Benghazi um the way I'm going to
do it today is as you see and I wrote a
book me and my co-author Dave boom
Benton um he's famous from 13 hours we
actually have done our own personal
investigation um to identify the actual
terrorists at the attacks but since we
have such a good mix of people here
today I thought let's just focus on
being in a crisis and what happens in a
crisis and the data that comes in during
a crisis so we're just going to walk
through the timeline and just talk about
the data that came in and may better
ways that could have have been
used and I'm not even going to explain
things we're almost going to go through
it like it's just going on in real time
like if something just happened here and
people came through the doors right so
at 9:42 p.m. in Benghazi and this is
only 3:42 in the afternoon in Washington
DC so whenever people say this happened
in the middle of the night here I don't
know where any of that comes from so
it's afternoon in Washington DC um the
CIA Annex I'm I'm from the CIA so they
get a phone call and saying hey there's
an attack over here at the consulate
um the really interesting thing is it
was a call and then when the call came
in someone like radioed his team like
team come and meet and they're like okay
we'll go meet it's like 10 at night and
then he got annoyed they didn't move
quick enough and U he's like no get here
now and then they walk out and hear
noise like oh there's an attack it's
like why did you not just say over the
radio hey there's an attack so obviously
first mistake right no sort of alerting
system you know there's a person in this
um consulate calling a bunch of people
let's just do do an alert system gets
sent out to everyone so through this um
presentation I'm using a tool called
it's by met mettis analytics I I just
picked this tool because you could be
sitting like in your office and input
stuff but also like teams on the ground
can like wear it on them and get some of
these alerts so obviously they could
have gotten alert quicker than the whole
weird radio game um so just showed you
what that looked like and then basically
you know what happens next is the teams
load up all their gear the times you're
going to see in my presentation are
basically taken off the surveillance
videos that either the CIA Annex or the
US Consulate just FYI where these actual
numbers are coming from so the team
loads up in vehicles obviously some of
the big questions they have right is
they're going to say the ambassador he's
he's the the person who matters the most
in any country um if you're overseas so
it's where's the Ambassador located they
luckily knew he would went to bed for
the night so they knew where he was but
obviously the other things that would
have been interesting to know as you can
imagine is who's with him right they
didn't know who was even in the building
with him so you know saying hey he's in
the building with two other people the
funny part is is um the buildings are
gone now so that's why there's points on
dirt so just FYI to the buildings from
the consulate no longer exists anymore
in imagery and I didn't want to be weird
and put in fake imagery um so then we
get the location of basically the two
agents who work in Benghazi all the time
that aren't with the Ambassador and then
two people came with the Ambassador so
sending those geoc cords too none of
these geoc cords were sent these people
they moved to these locations within the
first few minutes and stayed there for
an hour it would have been really good
for the rescue teams obviously to know
where everyone was on the compound it
would have sped up a lot of their
response
time another thing that really that
happened is they asked are the gates
breached the consulate was very simple
there was a gate at the front gate at
the back that's it so the attackers all
came and attacked from the front a
couple like little miscreant were like
hey I'm not going to do the attack Alca
wants me to do I'm going to steal a Land
Cruiser today so a couple guys go
straight to the back of the compound get
the keys so obviously one had worked on
the compound um and drive the land and
the funny thing is is you could clearly
they work there because they locked the
gate the sad part is in real time is you
can imagine it got reported the back
gate is breached it didn't nobody Circle
back around and said it wased breach for
like a minute and then they relocked it
and now there's no Terrace there so the
problem you know if you would have said
it was temporarily breached the team
actually would have gone to the back
gate because all of al-Qaeda was at the
front gate so you know it's just one of
those little things if you would have
got the update and they saw it on camera
in real time so we're at 10:05 now um
we're not going to discuss controversies
here but there's a lot of leaders in
this room okay you can collect the best
date in the world you can hire the best
talent in the world but if you have a
crappy boss which was the chief of Base
in Benghazi your team sits in a car for
19 minutes and doesn't get in the fight
it's factual this is when they leave
people always ask if the movie is
accurate this is from the movie they're
only off by five minutes so not too bad
so remember the
Mercedes CU we didn't just find the
Terrace we also found our belongings
because the US government seems to be
better at charging people looting um
which you'll learn our only terrorist in
our attack was charged for looting um
basically um so 3 minutes later these
compounds are super close to each other
so at 3 minutes they get up to basically
the main roadblock blocking entrance to
go to the main entrance of the compound
so they get out their vehicles and
there's some terrace running the
checkpoint and they have a whole
negotiation let us through let our
vehicles through and he's like hey I got
to call these anel Sharia guys to get
passage for you to go through so
obviously if you're using this tool back
you know this is all getting reported of
a radio it's kind of like who an Sol
Sharia and so we pull that up and you
know since I found all the attackers I
got everybody's photos so that'll be fun
um so basically you pull up in real time
if you're sitting on the CIA Annex just
so you know hey who are we interacting
with over here at the consulate and you
find out oh there's three Ansel Shas in
the area um all actually were involved
in our attacks we're not going to spend
too much time on terrist today but just
to go through them so people understand
Muhammad ran the Benghazi branch he knew
Bin Laden back during the Sudan days
very long relationship sufian B kumu A
lot of people know him he was in guantan
Bay Dy he worked for bin Laden's company
in Sudan he fought in
Afghanistan we're come back to mous
that's sufian um Deputy I didn't make up
the M name Mouse that's what the Terrace
say but you have to admit that looks
really good um like I was like yeah it
does look like a rat or a mouse and then
so they ran the Darna Branch was just a
city east of Benghazi saula ran the
Tunisia Branch he's a terrorist
everybody knows and nobody knows him so
for all of us that look around my age in
the room if you remember two days before
911 when obviously Al-Qaeda did the um
attack against um Amman sha massud right
so they were going to do 911 they're
like hey let's take out the key us Ally
in Afghanistan they sent in two suicide
bombers pretending to be press those
were his two Tunisian suicide
bombers so it's still all the same guys
20 plus years later being involved in
terrorist attacks so obviously they
don't convince anel Sharia to let to
have go down with the vehicles so they
break into three teams at the checkpoint
and they're like okay we're going to go
different directions into the consulate
you know to get at the
attackers
so the team that just starts to go
straight down the road all the ter in
front of them so it becomes a really big
gunfight and so what they do is the
first thing that happens is they shoot a
grenade launcher just towards the big
group of al-Qaeda at the main gate um
that scares everyone in al-Qaeda and
they all run off the compound that's it
one shot um the crazy part is so it's
all on camera and everyone in the State
Department inside knows it they watch
the camera and like oh my gosh all the
attackers are leaving so 3 minutes later
the the state department guy Peaks out
right he's like did that really happen
and he goes out the door and he looks
down like oh my God all the terorists
are gone they don't radio and tell CIA
hey all the terrorists have completely
left every inch of this compound so CIA
is still like climbing over walls and
nearby compounds and clearing random
buildings they never needed to clear so
CIA doesn't actually you don't see a
foot on surveillance camera till 10:30
so they just now waste another 16
minutes trying to make their way on to
an empty consulate because information
wasn't
shared so now we just get to a point in
the timeline so let's just say we're at
10:30 so everyone now is on the
consulate and as you can imagine the key
focus is finding the US ambassador there
was a fire starting at at his on his
Villa about 10 p.m. so now they're going
in and out of his Villa looking for him
and they do that till about 11:00 p.m.
and then 11:00 p.m. another attack
starts on the consulate the funny part
is nobody knows really who it is
Al-Qaeda has left um they thought maybe
in real time it was friendly so they're
like we got to be careful who we shoot
this could be like a response Force so
so so battle goes on like 10 or so
minutes and finally a drone comes over
the top of the console the famous drone
everybody's heard about that really
didn't do anything it was like a
camcorder right so the night of the
attacks the Drone was over in the city
of darnos that's a city to the east it
was collected on on Kumo remember we saw
him the GMO guy so they move it over
takes about an hour to get there um but
you know one of the things if you're an
anal in station right you're like hey we
got a drone now we can maybe collect
who's around the area we've hopefully
collected a little bit on you know the
idiots who brought their phones to the
terrorist attack which was pretty much
everybody um so
so oh no there we go so in real time
everybody here is eight guys who come up
for right real time so don't let the US
government tell you otherwise okay we
got eight terrorists on the screen seven
of these terrorists were attackers at
the consulate six of these terrorists
were Al-Qaeda and one's anaria which
makes sense the US government when
captured the one guy who was not an
attacker and told you he was a
mastermind so Amed Abu katala doing the
Libyan re Revolution he ran like a
militia with he he lived in a really
crappy neighborhood think Compton in its
Heyday the neighborhood was actually
called Kandahar that was the joke so him
and 20 guys from Kandahar had a little
militia During the Revolution and like a
lot of the small militias that didn't
really gain any kind of power it
disbanded after good off he fell so by
late 2011 it disbanded and he was mostly
working every day on his construction
site he's apparently a very good Builder
he's not good at anything terrorist wise
so because he's a little bit of a loose
cannon Al Kaiden and SAR Sharia told him
nothing about the attacks so he's at
home sipping tea and gets a call from a
couple of the guys from his militia back
in the day because they've now joined
anel Shar and other terrorist groups and
they're like hey we're down at the US
Consulate come down al-qaeda's attacking
and he's like no way so he goes down to
the consulate but it's even funnier he
hangs out outside until alqaeda
leaves um so yeah so that's anyway this
is the US Mastermind he got 20 22 years
in prison in the US justice system he's
a terrorist but he should be in Libya
charged for an assassination he did and
he'd have the death
penalty but so we W so so again Al-Qaeda
Al-Qaeda Al-Qaeda anaria alqaeda
Al-Qaeda Al-Qaeda so let's talk about
someone on the screen that actually
matters let's talk about Omar um because
the US is horrible at collecting real
names they call him Abu musab Al mansur
all liby but his name's Omar shele he is
the the Knight of the attacks and CIA
knew this person the Knight of the
attacks he was the aqim so that's
al-qaeda's North African Branch he was
their leader for all of Libya he arrived
the attacks at 9 o' and led the entire
attack on the ground right so the aqim
leader for Libya is on the ground
leading the
attacks and they don't even tell you aqs
then their leader for the whole country
is there so Omar is a very interesting
guy I'll go really quick um because
there just there's a lot of historical
stuff he grew up in a house with seven
brothers and three cousins yes it took
me a very long time to realize there is
three cousins so I was like why are
there so many men 10 of them all went
and fought in Iraq five of them died in
Iraq his brother Adele was super super
famous in Iraq after they came back to
Libya they had all been friends with the
leader of al-Qaeda in Iraq he also
founded Isis Abu musab Zara zakari gets
killed his brother Dell is like well I'm
going to go back and avenge his death
I'm going to go back to Iraq and blow
some Americans up he goes back gets
captured the night of 91112 Adele is on
death row in um Iraq so if people aren't
aware this operation by Al-Qaeda was not
to go kill Americans it was to go
capture the US ambassador and to swap
him for Terrace one of the most most
important Terrace they were going to
swap him for is Adele Al
shalele obviously he didn't get swapped
and he met his maker in Iraq um so now
we go to
basically it's been so long that they're
like if the Ambassador is in the
building he un fortunately must have
died a smoke elimation we found Sean
Smith he's deceased they really though
thought cu the terrist shot out some of
the cameras they really thought maybe
they just grabbed him and we missed it
so everyone decides to leave the
compound the first thing that happens
the state department goes and leaves um
the CIA says don't go X Direction
because there Terrace that way they
either don't hear it or Worse the one
guy that drove was the one that was in
the building with the Ambassador in
smoke inhalation so they picked the
worst guy to drive they go the wrong way
and they have a horrible vehicle Ambush
if you guys see this on camera it's way
worse than the movies like you think it
was fake it's like this car like Putters
up it's got like no wheels anymore and
it's like all shot up um again if there
was some sort of alerting system as
they're pulling out a GPS could be like
don't go this way so another key thing
that could have been
fixed then now everyone now moves over
to the CIA Annex just so people are
clear because there a lot of rumors
about this a lot of people like oh
people followed the state department
back and then they got shot with mortars
because of it um so as I told you
Al-Qaeda went to go capture the US
ambassador a whole another terrorist
group shot the mor at the CIA and they
knew where the CIA was where to where
that Terrace actually called it Bob's
house so no one had to follow the CIA
back to the annex to do a successful
mortar strike because they knew exactly
where it was they knew where it was from
the day it opened but in real time um
you know all the rescue forces get on
the CIA roofs because they're like okay
we assume attacks are going to happen
against us and three more attacks end up
happening that night and then this
annoying drone comes back now it's over
the CI Annex and it's like super close
right and they're like push off like you
should be looking for enemies and so
they send that to the Drone it never
gets to the Drone as you can all imagine
they got weird feedback back from the
Drone with old info but no one ever
through the phone game sent push off and
look for this so again if that would
have been done right um this is kind of
the one piece where we just make up a
time so we we say if that would have
been done right the Drone could maybe
have seen some of the enemy activity
that
um of people setting up the mortars
potentially and then the analyst and
stationer whomever is working the tool
you know could have put out um the fact
that there a mortar team setting up and
attack's occurring maybe it could have
happened maybe and not but it's just
showing you all in real time even when
you get little tidbits of information
they need to be shared you need to take
advantage of them because it really can
affect the timeline as we saw there's
delays just because because information
wasn't shared properly and the thing was
is while the consulate was still open
that the Diplomatic Security agent in
there was sharing everything like he is
like your dream man in a crisis right so
you had the right guy in the right spot
to share of course when everyone moved
the CIA compound nothing got shared and
nobody knew it was going on to where
actually a lot of the the Department of
Defense had no idea the attacks were
still even going on because the C CIA
wasn't sharing oh we have continued
attacks now on our Annex so there's a
lot of failures in the sharing um of
attack
information and that's basically the
overview so here's my details I work for
the Department of fense this is my
personal investigation with Boon as I
told you guys that's why I can say
whatever I want um if you wanted to know
about the platform you use that was
called mettis and that's um the CEO
Christian Johnson in his email and then
obviously our book you can get on Amazon
and Barnes & Noble I did bring some and
I can maybe sell them in the back I
asked Jake if that's allowed or not um
but if you're interested let me know and
I'll be here and if you have any
questions I can I'm happy to answer any
questions about Benghazi um we've
identified over
125 of the terorists there's over 150
Terrace just at the consulate alone and
then there's a 10man mortar team that
did the CIA um mortar strike so for the
10man mort team we we've just identified
the first member of that team so that's
the focus of our investigation right now
but our plan is to we think it'll take
five more years but we're going to
identify every single terrorist that
were at the attacks that that night
because our government didn't do it so
someone had to thank
[Applause]
you